okay
hello boys and girls my name is matt
walsh i am a children's author and i've
written a book called johnny the walrus
this book is all about identity and
imagination what is identity does anyone
know what identity means
do you know you know what identity is no
okay it's who you are right that's what
it means now who likes to pretend to be
things there's anything you like to
pretend to be how about in the
background
a ninja
that's a good one what about you
all right well we all like to use our
imagination sometimes i use my
imagination i pretend to be a monster i
chase my kids around because i'm big and
ugly so i could be a monster that's what
this book is about it's all about a boy
who pretends to be a walrus he
identifies as a walrus and his mom's a
little silly she takes it seriously and
thinks he really is a walrus that's
silly isn't
doing on the it that's we don't have to
worry about that we're going to read the
book now okay
johnny's a boy with a big imagination
one day he's a dog the next day a
crustacean it's like a crab or a lobster
one morning he came downstairs barking
and clapping wood spoons for tusks and
sock fins a flapping it spoons his mouth
he's pretending to be a walrus
i'm johnny the walrus he said with a
roar the wood floor is my ocean the
carpet's my shore she's swimming around
like a walrus isn't that silly
johnny's mom loves her son's
make-believe time you're johnny the
walrus till you change your mind mommy
says but johnny's mom's phone said it's
not just pretend
so she went on her phone and there are
people telling her that this isn't
pretend he's really a walrus
only a bigot would say that how dare you
offend what's a bigot anybody know
the mean person right
mommy was told to take john for a
checkup
all these people are holding signs
johnny is a real walrus one sign says
human walruses are real walruses let
johnny transition all these people are
saying you'll need to eat worms and to
put on gray makeup
[Music]
the worms give you whiskers the gray
blends you in the doctor says
and a simple procedure cuts feet into
fins
the doctor wants to cut
into johnny and make him into a walrus
that's scary it's gross eating worms mom
they're all so dang twitchy he doesn't
eat
i worms i didn't eat worms but i did
would spoons kind of hurt and the makeup
is itchy
deep down johnny's mom knew that
something was wrong look at johnny
he's dressed up like a walrus but he's
not having a fun time
but she felt so much pressure she just
went along
the internet people knew just what to do
she went back to the internet to look
for answers never a good idea
and mommy was told to take john to the
zoo now she's going to take her son to
go live at the zoo like he's a real
wally i don't want to live
when johnny arrived the walrus is
grunted
the mommy says my boy's a real walrus
his growth was just stunted she really
thinks this kid is a walrus
but he's not
no
the zookeeper thought what's she talking
about
ma'am that's just a boy with wood spoons
in his mouth now he's the voice of
reason
but if i believe that they'll say that
i'm phobic
protecting your son ma'am is what's most
heroic
at last johnny's mommy was able to see
that johnny's not what he's pretending
to be now mommy ignores the mean things
on her phone
while johnny pretends he's a bird flying
home
the end
thank you
[Applause]
i just sat down and wrote it
there's another one there we got a bunch
of them they're gonna be all over the
place soon enough you can ask your
parents to buy it for you
[Music]
is there is there a particular ending
we're looking for here just